اكثر من 400 جندي وضابط في الجيش
الاسرائيلي اقتحموا مخيم بلاطه شمال
الاراضي الفلسطينيه جزء منهم حاصر هذا
المنزل قبل ان تقوم وحده الهندسه العسكريه
التابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي بتفجيره بالكامل
صار
ت بعد العشر دقائق مع الدين الا للدار
كلها طارت
لو كنا نهينا لو كنا بالغرفه هذيك
بالصالون رحنا فيها
الجيش الاسرائيلي قتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين
واصاب العشرات بالرصاص والاختناق بالغاز
خلال مواجهات واشتباكات مسلحه دارت بين
الفلسطينيين والجيش الاسرائيلي في المخيم
بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي قال انه عثر على
مختبر للمتفجرات ففجره ما ادى الى تدمير
ثلاثه منازل بالكامل اضافه الى تضرر سبعه
منازل اخرى من مخيم بلاطه شمال الاراضي
الفلسطينيه خالد القاسم العربيه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات